christian is on the line he is in
orlando he is an attorney and he works
with other attorneys who've been sued
for trying to get people out of their
timeshares is that right did i say that
right
you did you got it dave and thank you
for everything you're doing
what in the world so you have people
that are
in the legal profession that are lawyers
that sue
a timeshare company to get people out of
their contracts
to abide by their contracts in some
cases which lets people out
and then they turn around and sue the
lawyer
companies i'm sorry you're you cut out
on me you cut out on me try it again
sorry about that babe right now yes sir
i am
you time share companies don't want
lawyers talking to them
about arbitration or resolving things
all they want is for time share owners
to shut up and have
annual maintenance fees doubled every
year
and my clients are just lawyers who
they recognize that timeshare industry
is the last legal fraud
in america and now they're being shaken
down in federal court these the big guys
you said it i mean
they're weaponizing the courts to shake
down
lawyers who help people get out of the
last legal
fraud in america it's shocking
wow and so you turn around and
you turn around and rep your client or
other attorneys who are trying to get
people out
that's right i represent how has that
grown how many of these cases have you
done and how is the
what's your success rate i i
currently have probably 15 cases
going on in state and federal court
most of these cases haven't resolved we
haven't even gotten to a trial
you know why we haven't gotten to a
trial dave because they want to beat you
to death financially
boom you got it they want to drag out
the billable hours until you dry up and
die
they want to make these guys spend
hundreds of thousands or
millions of dollars defending themselves
the
the insurance companies don't want to
pick up the tab you know
and so they force them out of business
through litigation
and it's sham litigation they're not
investigating these lawyers ahead of
time to see if they're good or bad
my guys in missouri they were they just
had these salacious allegations
and it puts them out of business but
dave we did they lose their law practice
because they can't afford to contin
continue to defend themselves against
this company who has infinitely deep
pockets oh by the way their pockets were
lined by people they screwed
right and they're desperate to keep them
lined
my clients are just folks who they
haven't given up yet you know they
haven't
given up they're not settling they keep
going in fact we filed a counter claim
against
windham and bluegreen for antitrust
and this morning we asked a judge to
enjoy
these guys from continuing any other
lawsuits against my client
until we resolve whether the arda
and their buddies windham diamond blue
green
did a concerted conspiracy anti-trust
designed to make themselves stronger and
to screw the consumers we think that's
exactly what they've done
they announced it from the stage mike
flasky
the ceo of diamond announced that he was
putting up a million dollars and
challenged the other people in the arda
to come together and collude
to run exeters out of business
and and if the ftc isn't going to look
at it that means we have to so that's
what we're doing
wow i'm a little shocked i have a
a a huge respect for federal judges and
i'm a little shocked they're tolerating
this in their courts
dave i don't think they are you know
although it's they they started this
anti-trust stuff probably about two or
three years ago like really going at it
but i've noticed in the last six months
these federal judges like you said
they're sharp
and they're the tide is turning you can
tell
there's little orders that are coming
out like i told you none of these have
really been resolved yet
but the little orders that are coming
out they're starting to note
that the dockets are being flooded with
these cases that seem to go on forever
and ever
and in the few cases that have had a
summary judgment
granted or something like that it's
usually in the favor
of the good guys so i think
but that's after they've dropped 200 000
or they didn't have and legal fees into
the thing
the good guy you're right you're right
you're right and so it's going to take
one someone maybe my clients maybe
someone else
to give them a bloody nose and show them
that this frivolous litigation can't
stand
and i think we will yeah well
they've come after us now and that was a
mistake because i have deep enough
pockets to fight them
and i have 22 million listeners and i'm
going to beat the snot out of them
picking on you wouldn't be my idea of a
good time well
they did and it was a mistake they sent
inside addition
to do an ambush in the lobby of the
hotel where we were doing an event
last week and mary guerrero and charlie
mckelvie come in there which are known
for their intelligence anyway
but they do one of these ambush
interviews mr ramsay mr ramsey why are
you endorsing timeshare exit team
mr ramsey and ambushed me in the front
of the dadgum
lobby of this hotel but there's no way
inside edition does that
without these bozos causing it
yeah right because inside edition's not
that smart to start with
mary's not that smart for sure okay
i mean she's not known for her brains
she's known for other stuff
but oh my gosh y'all this is what's
going on out there
yeah so i get i get you're going to see
me on a duck and cover in one of these
dadgum inside edition things coming up
this weekend probably
but unbelievable hey man thank you for
calling
thanks for talking to us i'm going to
tell you guys a story in this next
segment
it's going to blow your minds it goes
right with what christian's saying
this is the ramsey show